so listen it brings me no pleasure to
have to tell you this but at this point
you should all know I don't
strategically censor or tailor my
coverage of this primary to serve
personal political purposes I've told
you one of the reasons that there are
many Democratic primary voters that
aren't into voting for Bernie Sanders
and why indeed he may have it wasn't a
20% sealing the way corporate media told
us wasn't 25 it wasn't 30 but Bernie may
have a ceiling of about 38 39 percent
nationally in the Democratic primary the
reason in part that that's going on is
Bernie has a long history of having
toxic people around him just just really
toxic people I've talked about it before
and we have another example and it's
really bad I mean it is really really
just bad politics to have these people
around him a couple of nights ago Bernie
had a rally in Dearborn Michigan because
Michigan votes today
it's basically do or die for Bernie
Sanders if he can't win Michigan and by
a sizable margin he's essentially done
and there are new Michigan polls that
don't look good for Bernie so he's smart
he's spending time in Michigan doing a
Fox News Town Hall doing rallies okay
Bernie was introduced a couple of days
ago in Dearborn Michigan by an imam imam
al hassan kazooie nee from the Islamic
Institute of America our TV and video
audience is currently seeing video from
the rally with the Imam speaking now
this was not some random person on
Twitter who supports Bernie this is
someone invited to introduce Bernie at
this rally the same Imam has promulgated
conspiracy theories about how Isis is
connected to Israel
Isis is playing the role of Zionists in
the Muslim world suggesting Israel may
even be connected to Isis isn't it
suspicious that Isis hasn't done attacks
in Israel and this may all be a ploy by
the so-called Zionists to use Isis as a
puppet to kill Muslims in different
countries check out the Imams
theory and I used that term very loosely
presented in a video isis has targeted
people
in Lebanon in Syria in Iraq in Kuwait
Saudi Arabia in Pakistan in Afghanistan
in Yemen in Algeria the only place the
only place that has been completely safe
and has never been a threatened by Isis
nor it has been targeted is Israel what
does this tell you this speaks out this
speaks volumes that Isis somehow is
connected to Israel and Isis is a
playing the wrong of the arm of the
Zionists in the Muslim world to kill
more Muslims and non-muslims so it can
define the name of Islam so people can
blame Islam for its atrocities so people
would be eliminated from this religion
this peaceful religion our religion
otherwise who's benefiting and
benefiting from these atrocities Muslims
are benefiting guys this is just bad
there's no excuse for this there these
are toxic people around Bernie this may
be one of the worst ones the same Imam
has bragged about his close relationship
with Mohamed Hussein Fadlallah who is a
cleric linked to the terrorist group
Hezbollah the same Imam has supported
Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad guys
this is bad for Bernie this is really
bad this is not about I'm against
medicare-for-all
this is not about I'm against College of
a public college tuition this is not
about I'm against higher marginal tax
rates these are just bad people to have
around you if you're trying to win a
National Democratic primary you know we
talked about Bernie's policies they're
the most progressive we talked about
here's how we pay for this stuff here's
how we pay for that stuff
Bernie falters on super Super Tuesday
and I point out you know there's a lot
of moderate Democrats in the primary
electorate this is a problem for Bernie
Bernie has some toxic people around him
battle
these moderate Democrats are repelled by
I've been warning about these toxic
people for years it's do or die for
Bernie in Michigan it's do or die for
Bernie tonight he has to win and quite
frankly he has to win more than just
Michigan tonight and he brings in a guy
who has a theory about Isis being
connected to Israel to introduce him at
a rally it's disappointing and sad like
I'm not even mad in any sense these are
just terrible campaign decisions
absolutely terrible campaign decisions
and you know I mean we all know the
direction this is going we're gonna have
plenty of time to sort of look at what
happened here and think through mistakes
that were made and you know it it's not
about Monday morning quarterbacking I've
been saying this for five years about
some of the people around Bernie Sanders
but this is just like the lowest of the
low what are we doing how this is not
how you build an effective widely
appealing progressive movement in the
United States it's just not and the
numbers reflect it the numbers reflect
it and that's just it so I you know
people are gonna be mad
we're gonna dislike the video people
start tweeting about why it why am I
talking about this I'm talking about
this because it's a problem I identified
years ago and at the worst possible time
when everything is riding on tonight's
elections this is who's introducing
Bernie could give me a break it's just a
terrible whoever made this decision I
don't know I would love to hear what
exactly they were thinking let's go to
your voicemails the voicemail number is
two one nine to david p the audience is
in disagreement over Bernie's chances in
these still ongoing for now Democratic
primary
here is one viewer who says you will not
stop Bernie Bernie is getting the
nomination take a listen